direction dijon maintenant on le
retrouve en direct dominique verdeilhan
alors dominique effectivement des ce dès
le premier jour tous les éléments du
procédé est en place oui tout à fait
avec lord au soir de cette première
journée on peut déjà faire un constat on
a plus parlé de bernard laroche et de
muriel bolle que de jean marie villemin
c'est dire que le déjà le volet grégory
laroche a pris le pas sur le volet
villemain alors un glissement évidemment
qui a ravi la défense avec aujourd'hui
un personnage clé qui est le personnage
clé de ce dossier de ce procès muriel
bolle l'épicentre d'un séisme familiale
selon l'expression de m chastan un
glissement qui en revanche est redouté
par la partie civile qui ne souhaite pas
que ce procès soit celui d'un mort
bernard laroche le planning des cinq
semaines à venir et pourtant éloquent 16
journées entières seront consacrés à
l'assassinât du petit grégory six
journées seulement à l'assassinât de
bernard laroche
merci d'indiquer que